I threw out my [ __ ] bodies tell me
that didn't gravely [ __ ] up but I'm
going to just do this because that's who
is your a showman thank you I am hey
what's going on everybody for first week
beast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot one it's the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings and today by
popular demand I'm joined by Steve oh
you're no one from jackass and wild boys
you can catch them on the stand-up stage
and oh yeah he has a YouTube channel
where you still doing it steve-o saying
casual 4 million subs no big deal
steve-o welcome to the show thank you
for having me an honor to be here you
have an incredible pain tolerance but
how are you with hot food specific I
can't stand eating anything without hot
sauce for the most part but when we get
into the zone of [ __ ] up hot which we
do right but I'm going to play balls as
much as until like one my but when I
feel the it's time to stop I'm not going
to beat myself up if I do don't be a
superhero right it's ok and we're just
happy that you're at the table and maybe
if I do decline to go to the next hot
sauce maybe I can still take the next
salacious ill-advised question let me
let me just burn bridges and [ __ ] [ __ ]
up for the interview
[Music]
I came here starving I have not had my
girlfriend made me avocado toast this
morning here we are at par 5 in the
afternoon have an 8 and [ __ ] and then
they're already on there oh yeah you
don't have to add more unless you wanna
tell you I love this [ __ ] you know the
doctors say don't [ __ ] with the hot
dozen I do yeah right off the bag like I
have like an acid reflux thing and then
just for balance is none other than one
so I want to start by taking it back to
the University of Miami I love it
because college is very much ground zero
for the watch this hold my beer behavior
that you ended up building a career
right aha if camera phones were around
back then what would be some of the
things on your highlight reel well then
I'm sure I would have footage of the
time when I broke my skull you know that
said it kills me I threw myself off a
balcony at the University of Miami I
landed on my face on the concrete below
I broke my cheekbone and I broke seventy
ten stitches in my chin a concussion and
a broken wrist all in one fall and I
laid there face down with a pool of
blood growing around my head was a king
party on campus
everyone's like wow he's dead I mean I
wasn't even twitching a finger and my
buddy and I had the lead in my pocket I
said if she's not dead he's kind of made
that Reed so they came in like pulled it
out of my pocket I going through my pod
gone through the dead guy's pockets to
take his weed
it's a sketchy you seen if you're just
back go down right the next morning I
broke out of the hospital I been living
his apartment called my buddies at the
university i said hey swing through the
ER can break me out of here and I broke
out in my gown with my blood hanging out
and I went back to the spot where I
landed in the blood on the concrete and
tried to Pat a beer and my sinuses would
just fill with blood and then I'd go
through like Hocking up a liddie and
just spit blood ladies into the bowl of
applesauce
which I couldn't eat the fact that
you're here today Steve oh now I know
the house [ __ ] can I survive that
so between jackass the movies wild boys
I have a million questions about beanbag
shotguns and stapling your hops to stuff
whatever you want man whatever you want
do you remember the first time you ever
got arrested doing a stuff I guess the
first time I got arrested around a stunt
was when I was charged formally with a
felony for obscenity in Louisiana for
stapling my nutsack to my leg what do
you think the closest you've ever been
to dying on camera I'm so confident that
it would be a scuba-diving I just like
didn't pay attention when I they taught
me how to scuba dive I don't even know
what country are we were in but I was
told the Sharks were at the bottom
that's something about it when always
the bottom and then someone was up I
felt some grab my sins and they're like
well and then when we got up top the guy
said you [ __ ] you almost died
and I almost died trying to save you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't you know like
something about scuba diving that I just
don't understand and then what was the
most savage off camera prank that was
ever Bob yeah what a great question that
is there was the one that was actually
on camera but a little known about
because it lived on a and an obscure DVD
that I put up on myself I filmed myself
ejaculating onto the computer keyboard
and desk of the most germaphobic
producer of Jackass back in the early
days and TV shows and then I wanted to
go in there and film him to type in away
okay so yeah but my blabbermouth I had
told too many people so I found out
about and really forensic Lee claimed
everything so when I went to film him I
found him giving me the most hilarious
lecture if ever you know tear up and
you're on your way back to Florida when
reality finally said something man
there's a lot of stuff I could have a
deal where I was too busy jacking off on
Scott's - gasps have a condiment
disorder so I'm just I'm going to add
the Valentina
when you jump off of a 35 foot overpass
from the bed of a moving truck what
happens beforehand is there physics is
there math are there sketches or is it
more just a grip it falls to the wall
right whatever happens happens mentality
there is no practice in that one because
that it was pretty illegal you went up
on foot and scattered the bridge
realizing that really you had to meet
that window you couldn't beat it earlier
late because you would hit pylons you
know I mean it was important to get the
timing right normally in a situation
like that when it's a difficult thing a
dangerous thing
one two three go is my tool you know one
two three go and count that and I have
never backed out of a one two three go
in my life oh no all right let's switch
gears and talk about stand up for a wink
what man do you remember the last time
you had to kick out a heckler I've had
pretty good run I'm not having to do
that let me hate having to do that yeah
I think about heckling is that it kind
of conjures up just the word heckling
conjures up the image is somebody witty
somebody challenging the comic like in a
way that's kind of confrontational and
then it's the onus on the comic to be
witty and shut them down but that one
just brilliant
sort of burned that change them and
quiets them but that's not the
experience you know it's just some drunk
guy screaming 90% of the time it's just
drunk people that and there's no making
sense with them with that said I can be
pretty mean and I like it
there have been times when when I when I
totally lost my cool get the [ __ ] out
come out you know and in there
particularly with like the video and
with the cellphones it's so insidious in
New Zealand I went off on a cataract
shut her up and up they wrote a [ __ ]
article about what a dick I was in New
Zealand and it's like this you know here
I was worried about one leg days because
I could someone can approach the video
of my show how many people are going to
see that on this person's face what a
handful but then I write the story about
you everybody know I google search on
the latest news let's see about what a
dick you know yells in a poor girl oh
[Music]
you had your own sauce how about that
yeah I'm like doing less dunking now all
right so we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that Graham and
what we do is we do a deep dive and our
guest Instagram we pull interesting
pictures I don't need more context so
I'll show a picture and then you just
tell me the bigger story that's I'm good
you got it all right last hop please
first and foremost what's going on in
this picture
okay that was in st. Louis two years ago
at a summer concert festival I performed
my famous double back meaning I dropped
my dick involves back and forth
violently until jumping up in the air
and classroom my thighs together
catching the back burger and then pull
down my ass my boxer shorts revealing
the mangina to 15,000 people
I had to pixelate dick involves
protruding from my rear for Instagram
strict guideline policy right but
snapchat let that one slide undercover
clown with Justin Bieber
it wasn't actually planned and when we
were out in clown makeup filming it in
Venice he's pranking people and do all
his crazy [ __ ] and lo and behold that's
Justin Bieber just plain blamed a
walking and I went I'm German and say yo
G what's that man and he goes Steve oh
man recognized you right away and like
wow like hey dude so we started
skateboarding in the Venice skate park
together she signed a release form to be
in my video put it out and then like
maybe a week later he was uh all over
the news for making some kind of racist
joke in an age-old video that had
surfaced there's all this negative
publicity and the very people who paid
me asked me to make the video private
because Justin Bieber was like
radioactive so yeah so all the money
they gave me which it hurt nothing I
have one more for ya this is an adorable
picture nine years old the team was
called the Kendall Broncos what's great
about this isn't that picture but that I
was wearing that same uniform shoulder
pads and everything when I went in to
get my passport photo taken for my
Canadian citizenship card this is so
incredible because like always as a
child I was just uncomfortable in my own
skin which is pretty par for the course
for alcoholics and stuff that's why you
know and like I just felt that in my
football uniform that I was more I am
mounted to more I always had my
announcement my in my costume that made
me feel there I wanted to grow my little
Mullis because I was like a head meddler
you know and I had as my identity and
then it was like skateboarding and then
it was pot jumping ah but always like I
had to have that like identity you're in
a phase you were in a you're out of
phase perpetually enough fame has never
just comfortable to be
me and my own skin well you look like
you're comfortable in your skin I've
made a lot of progress in that area and
I appreciate you saying so this one's
dirty dick an aggressive brand name ok
dirty dick how about that
I once recorded a rap song called down
with STDs good sounds like a good a
dirty dick surmising that I recorded it
on a night when I was smoking so much
PCP that I actually blacked out came to
discovered that I had destroyed the
studio and the studio was the studio of
famed gangster rap actually named Fame
of MLP he don't [ __ ] with that guy you
know break his ship no but I would so
[ __ ] up that night on PCP recording
down with STDs that I lost a $20,000
Rolex man and for all I know I [ __ ]
man way to give it away
one sec let me to be unprofessional here
for a sec do it do it oh Knoxville
Cheyenne trim oh yeah you should yeah I
need yeah hey man um I can't really talk
right now because I'm doing this thing
called hot ones where I eat like
originally hot [ __ ] while answering
salacious ill-advised questions oh my
good night getting harder than Portland
important cement just think of it is
right and so I just figure that answer
on speakerphone to show off I just got a
call from the captain okay well you do
your thing sounds like you're busy and
yeah it didn't always I'm unavailable
for Hammer sure man I can't wait to tell
your funny stories okay buddy
all right all right thanks
right captain the captain captain them
so as we've talked about already we're
eating vegan wings you've been very
vocal about being an animal advocate
over the last five years right so I want
to talk about the time that you scaled a
hundred foot crane 50 150 foot crane
over here on sunset right you're
protesting SeaWorld right and I remember
it being pandemonium I remember thy
merchants Evo I remember it had very
much sort of like a standoff not only
was it emergency vehicles then and
they'll just backtrack looking back at
how dumb could I have been right I mean
I went to go protest SeaWorld add a
random construction site nowhere near
SeaWorld I mean right out of the gate
we're talking stupid 150 feet up in
there nobody can see your stupid [ __ ]
toy whale the high you know like
pointless now I'm climbing up and not
people called 911 I got the [ __ ]
whale inflated shortly thereafter there
weren't just emergency responders there
were specifically as the police report
says 80 firefighters 18 cops a
helicopter and a SWAT team
I had these these artillery shells that
you know you light them in the tube and
they shoot up in the sky make a big
display but when I do is I just tape
them to the crane itself so they did not
have the opportunity to travel anywhere
so that when I lit them arm's length
away from my body there's a full blast
designed to make a display in the sky is
an arm's length away from you know ib2
animal hundred feet up in theirs to show
that I'm Marley and I used my inflatable
whale as a shield to protect me from the
blast
the problem was last occurred while the
police helicopter was circling around me
and added to a million striking criminal
charges five in total God they threw the
goddamn book and I deserved it I
remember reading the reports at the time
and you are facing something like four
and a half years or sayings like that
no you never end up like my friend I
never had sex but were you worried
probation jail time like any of that
wasn't worried about at all what it was
is the restitution once you start adding
up 80 [ __ ] firefighters 18 cops and
plus I was on the crane for good our
half I mean [ __ ] helicopter sir car you
got a sink a restitution to the City of
California everybody guest like kid
that's going to be 200 grand easy you
know you guys I can pay that back my dad
was like wow that was done but knock
show me who's like hey bud you know
that's going to be an expensive one hope
you got a good lawyer and I honestly
don't know I do know why didn't just
come down as soon as the first cop
showed up because I had promised that I
think I had promised I was going to
light fireworks really high in the air I
had to keep my word yeah yeah let
anybody down and you do this the same
thing every interview did you get you
here so there's nothing that surprises
me you know but I do feel it you know
I'm human it's really [ __ ] rock the
boat on this one well trying to keep it
off the ledge to have that smart
that's smart yeah I [ __ ] up over here
okay all right here we go let's talk
about YouTube because I think that in a
lot of ways jackass is sort of
low-budget
do-it-yourself extremeness literally
paved away for a lot of what you see on
YouTube right now but I want to talk
about the stunts and the pranks
specifically because it's such a crowded
competitive and congested space on
YouTube right
do you think that YouTube is pushing
that sort of art forward or is it taking
a step back do you ever think about it I
think what made jag as successful is
that the spirit of it was very positive
I mean granted yeah we were in
destructive self-harm
very mean to each other so we never
targeted innocent bystanders right never
were mean-spirited to anybody outside of
us that is what's lost on a lot of
YouTube pranksters you see a lot of
mean-spirited pranks going on and it
goes by its wildly popular and
successful and it's upsetting for me to
see that at the same time YouTube really
exploded between the second jackass
movie and the third and by the time the
third jackass movie came around we were
scouring YouTube for ideas right yeah
so I mean again it's a in in step
forwards that backwards there's so much
going on that you can't just make one
claim about what YouTube is good or bad
for
I threw out my [ __ ] body's Tommy Dunn
didn't gravely [ __ ] up but I'm going
to just do this because that's who is
you're a showman Thank You IRA Schulman
[Music]
getting through Megadeth sauce I like
that it's good name so growing up I know
that you idolized rock stars
specifically of the 80s hair metal era
so what I've done is I've pulled up some
icons from the genre I just want to show
them to you and then just get your snap
reaction to them that's all right I love
it
a man Tommy Lee t-bone bless his heart I
mean good dude
I could through the whole story about
how I met my lead crew when I was a
little kid they were in my town I was 13
I called every Hotel in the Yellow Pages
asking for a room by the name of their
manager got through and was lucky enough
this brother of the manager answered and
was impressed by my initiative and put
me on the list for backstage passes so
there wasn't that much crazy that
happened backstage that night
necessarily didn't have anything
pressing to ask or discuss with them but
by the virtue of the fact that I was
standing next to these guys through my
own sheer perseverance and initiative it
just empowers me man I was like [ __ ] I
made this happen here I am with Molly
[ __ ] crew I think that I took that
attitude largely through the rest of my
life you know with me like like I can
[ __ ] do anything were you a Sebastian
Bach guy of course he's notorious for
getting roped into a terrible contract
by Jon Bon Jovi I think Jon Jon Bon Jovi
should be more [ __ ] accountable for
being a [ __ ] dickwad [ __ ] screwing
people over business-wise you hear about
his relationship with Richie Sambora but
I understand the Jon Bon Jovi really
[ __ ] over Sebastian Bach he just
skates around like it's in half
[ __ ] Jon Bon Jovi
they're already on there so it's funny
that you say that it's tradition around
here to put a little dab on the last
wing this is our hat once off they've
called the last down you don't have you
don't have to take more than a little
bit you don't have to if you don't want
it you don't have I'm not going to do a
dab I'm going to compromise with the
Schmeer Schmeer you had people Schmeer
Schmeer Schmeer is a relatively popular
right workaround and I think it's fair
all right
you don't know what's coming out of that
bottle you rather can fool them right
see if I would say this on a reaction
level you're very chill I know that you
came in here with that my dad taught me
one motto in life
mm-hmm always under-promise and
over-deliver
you
you know here we are at the end of our
episode mm-hmm kind of feel sorry for
the poor guy who had to edit it so much
gold steve-o as we discussed today your
man who has long had Hollywood dreams
and through Simon with sharks and
jumping off of buildings and putting
hooks through your face you've been able
to realize those dreams you really are a
living example of how you can do
anything you want in this world and
that's coming from a guy who eats
chicken wings on YouTube holy [ __ ] I'm
like where the [ __ ] is the teleprompter
this guy's good there your impressive
talent I'm impressed by you okay thank
you I like this in my new motto in life
it doesn't really matter what you want
it just matters how badly you want it
well yeah what if you wanna be an NBA
players nothing happens you know of
course there's limitations but whatever
you want to [ __ ] do get off your ass
and start [ __ ] doing it and then when
the ships there if you're ready for it
you'll be on it and you're gonna sail
and then solve it and that's all you
need to know and you know what also
people need to know why that you made it
through let you heard the board that you
came in and dominated the vegan chicken
ride and now there's just one thing left
to do this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life and I'm living my
life in a way where I can look myself in
the mirror and and believe like I'm a
good person and and I have a
relationship with the universe a lot of
people like to call it God you know and
by the virtue of that fact I can look in
the mirror and see great hair wrinkles
I'm cool is it man you know I'm cool
with it dude I'm in a good place
that I actually battled the [ __ ] heat
consciously thinking man I don't want
this [ __ ] distraction [ __ ]
watering down my episode like let me too
quickly
Gaston the interview let me too quickly
and try not to let my speech be overly
affected
hello world Sean Evans coming at you to
say thank you for watching if you liked
what you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the 3000th rank
YouTube channel in the world it has been
a childhood dream of mine to be
somewhere in the mid twos we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please jk jk no
pressure but if you do subscribe I
appreciate it